[Music]
I'm gonna have to earn it Dolly Parton
is officially earning her Rockstar
status following her recent induction
into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
during an appearance on the view the
queen of country music revealed who will
be featured on her upcoming rock album
and let me tell you there's no shortage
of a-listers you took our way back with
Mick Jagger any chance of getting him to
record with you
oh well I'm doing my best to try to get
him on and but I did his song anyway I
think pink and uh Brandi Carlile are
going to be singing on that particular
song with me but we got great artists
like uh Paul McCartney is singing with
me and we got uh we got a lot of
Wonderful Stevie Nicks we just finished
our song oh that's gonna be so good now
dolly also teased a new duet with none
other than fellow music icon [ __ ] I've
been you know getting a song for her
we've been trying to get the right thing
together but that's going to be a big a
big story
[Applause]
when I recently sat down with Dolly she
revealed what inspired her to create a
rock album in the first place I thought
well timing is everything and I my
husband had always told me I should do a
rock album because he is a huge I mean
heavy metal Rock and roller and so
um I I thought well maybe I will someday
but then when they wanted to induct me
into the Hall of Fame and I didn't think
I deserved it then when they put me in
anyway I thought well I'm going to not
waste this time and so we're going to
have some classic singers and some
classic songs and some originals and I'm
calling it Rockstar about why not of
course because I'm a rock starter also
during her appearance on The View Dolly
opened up about the shocking death of
Lisa Marie Presley I was just
heartbroken for Priscilla as well as the
world being you know so shocked and
horrified by the early death of some
special wonderful girl so it's just a
feels like a family I was just talking
about how we all love that family and
it's as if it's our own but it's a
tragic thing